I WON'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUCKLE UP.
THIS IS THE WEEK THAT WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL REALLY GET
TO SEE FOR THE FIRST TIME JUST
HOW EXTREME, CRAZY, INSANE THESE
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS REALLY
ARE.
THIS IS A SNEAK PREVIEW.
MORE COMING UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CAN CANCEL STUDENT LOAN
DEBT FOR 95% OF THE FOLKS.
>> WE WILL DEMAND THAT WEALTHY
AND LARGE CORPORATIONS WILL PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF TAXES.
>> Sean: THIS WILL BE UGLY AND
YOU WILL BE SHOCKED AND IT WILL
HELP DONALD TRUMP.
YOU HAVE A FRONT ROW SEAT TO ALL
OF IT.
WE WILL HAVE A PREVIEW COMING
UP.
A "HANNITY" SPECIAL
MINI-MONOLOGUE.
FIRST A FOX NEWS ALERT.
DEEP STATE ABUSE OF POWER IS
UNDENIABLE.
TONIGHT WE HAVE BRAND NEW
DOCUMENTS WE WILL SHOW YOU.
ACCORDING TO THESE JUST RELEASED
DOCUMENTS OBTAINED BY THE
AMERICAN CENTER FOR LAW AND
JUSTICE AND A REQUEST, WE HAVE
SOME OF THE CLEAREST EVIDENCE TO
DATE OF WHAT IS NOTHING SHORT OF
AN ATTEMPTED COUP.
A SOFT COUP AGAINST THIS
PRESIDENT.
THESE DOCUMENTS SHED MORE LIGHT
ON THIS TIMELINE OF CORRUPTION
AND AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
UNDERMINE, FIRST STOP AND
PREVENT A PRESIDENT FROM WINNING
THEY DIDN'T LIKE AND RIG AN
ELECTION.
THEN TO UNDERMINE THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
A LONG TIME WHILE BACK WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS A LOT.
HOW THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IN
THEIR FINAL DAYS VASTLY EXPANDED
THE INTELLIGENCE SHARING
CAPABILITIES OF AMERICA'S MOST
POWERFUL AGENCIES.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS EXECUTIVE
ORDER P. IT WAS THE BASIS OF ALL
OF THIS.
I WAS WARNING ABOUT THIS AS FAR
BACK AS 2017.
NOWADAYS BEFORE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S INAUGURATION, THE
OFFICERS OF DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE PUSHED TO OVERHAUL
THE SHARING OF RAW INTELLIGENCE
WHICH EXPANDED THE SHARING OF
THIS RAW INTELLIGENCE FROM JUST
THREE AGENCIES TO 15.
-- 17.
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO IMPOSE
STANDARDS ON THE IN COMING
ADMINISTRATION.
STANDARDS THEY NEVER IMPOSSESSED
ON THEMSELVES FOR 8 YEARS?
ACCORDING TO NEW DOCUMENTS, THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICE WAS EAGER TO
GET THE NEW PROCEDURES SIGNED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BEFORE THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
NOT ONLY THAT, AROUND THE SAME
TIME THE GENERAL COUNSEL WROTE:
I REALLY WANT TO GET THIS DONE
AND SO DOES THE BOSS, LIKELY
REFERENCE TO CLAPPER.
ANY CHANCE THAT THE BOSS IS
OBAMA?
WHAT DID OBAMA AND BIDEN KNOW?
HOPEFULLY WE WILL GET ANSWERS
ONE DAY.
ALL OF THIS RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
HAPPENED ON THE BIDEN AND OBAMA
WATCH.
EVEN DEVIN NUNES WAS WARNING THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT RUSSIA
WAS GOING TO DO ALL OF THIS.
HE WARNED THEM IN EARLY 2014.
THEY DID NOTHING.
IT HAPPENED ON THEIR WATCH; NOT
TRUMP'S WATCH.
THE NSA DISCUSSED IN JANUARY
2017, IT COULD HAVE A SIGNATURE
FROM THE AGE THIS WEEK PRIOR TO
THE 20th OF JANUARY IS.
THAT WOULD BE THE DATE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S INAUGURATION.
FOR 8 YEARS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID WAN
ADMINISTRATION DID PIN
ADMINISTRATION DID PIT
ADMINISTRATION DID WAT
ADMINISTRATION DID WANT  NOT
SHARING THE INFORMATION IS ALL
17 AGENCIES, THEY ONLY ALLOWED
3.
>> THEN THERE WAS A COMPLETE
OVERHAUL OF INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING TO GIVE A LOT MORE
ACCESS TO SENSITIVE AND RAW AND
NOT CONFIRMED FEDERAL TO DEEP
STATE BUREAUCRATS WITHOUT
GETTING ANY INPUT FROM THE NEW
IN COMING ADMINISTRATION.
IT WAS SIGNED BY LORETTA LYNCH.
SOME OF THE SAME PEOPLE INVOLVED
IN THE PHONEY RUSSIAN COLLUSION
PROBE.
WHAT HAPPENED ON THE TARMAC IN
PHOENIX, ARIZONA, WHEN SHE SAID
HE WAS TALKING TO BILL CLINTON
FOR 45 MINUTES ABOUT GRAND KID
JUST DAYS SHE IS SUPPOSED TO
MAKE A DECISION WHETHER TO
INDICT HIS WIFE OR NIGHT.
HILLARY CLINTON'S EXXONERATION
WITHOUT AN INVESTIGATION.
EXPANDING ACCESSION TO THIS
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MATERIAL
MEANT IT WAS HARDER TO TRACE THE
INFORMATION AND WEED OUT THE
LEAKERS AND HARDER TO HOLD
ANYONE IN THE DEEP STATE
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY WERE TRYING TO PUT THE
INTELLIGENCE ON THE RADAR OF AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE SO THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO FIND THE
PEOPLE WHO KNEW WHAT THEY DID
WAS CORRUPTION.
IT'S BEING EXPOSED ANYWAY.
LOOK AT HOW URGENT THESE
MESSAGES ARE.
THEY HAD TWO WEEKS TO GET THIS
DONE.
DEEP STATE IN A MAD SCRAMBLE.
LOOKS LIKE CLAPPER WAS LEADING
THE WAY.
COMBINED WITH WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON ILLEGALLY
FUNNELING MONEY THROUGH A LAW
FIRM AND HIRING CHRISTOPHER
STEELE WHO PUT TOGETHER A BUNCH
OF DOCUMENTS THAT BECOMES THE
DIRTY RUSSIAN COLLUSION THAT WAS
USED TO RIG THE 2016 ELECTION
AND LIKE THEY RIGGED THE PRIMARY
AND STOLE IT FROM BERNIE
SANDERS.
IT'S ALL COMING INTO FOCUS.
NOW GETTING CLEARER EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING AWAY WITH
THIS.
WE TOLD YOU THE CURTAIN WAS
LIFTED.
IT IS.
YOU HEARD THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
ACT 1 THE MUELLER REPORT, IT'S
GONE.
ACT 2 NOW THE DEEP STATE, AND
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA MOB,
THEY KNOW THE DAY OF RECKONING
IS NEAR.
LOOK AT THE COWARDARDLY SHIFT
WHO IS PANICS BECAUSE HE IS
RUNNING OUT OF TIME TO INTERVIEW
MUELLER AND CONTINUE WITH HIS
ENDLESS CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THE GREAT IRONY EVERY TIME I
LOOK AT THIS IDIOT WHO WON'T
COME ON OUR SHOW.
IS THAT HE IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
WE HAVE ON TAPE CONSPIRING WITH
SOMEONE HE THINKS IS A RUSSIAN
TO GET DIRT TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE BEEN IN PRIVATE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL OFFICE.
WE ARE NEGOTIATING CONDITIONS OF
THE APPEARANCE.
WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
EITHER HE WILL COME IN VOLUN
VOLUNTARILY OR WE WILL HAVE TO
SUBPOENA HIM.
WE WANT HIM TO COME IN JULY.
THAT WILL BE THE CASE.
>> Sean: WE HAVE A DOSSIER ON
THE COWARDLY SCHIFF.
HIS JUST OWN LIES THAT HE
DIGGINS A DEEPER HOLE EVERY DAY
WITH.